So now that we've learned how the brain sends an receives signals, let's talk
about how the brain functions. Now the brain isn't just one big black box where
there's one unique function. It's actually made up of several important parts,
each with a unique purpose. Now just like we learned in the evolution material,
the brain is the result of millions of years of development. At the broadest
level, there are three major regions of the brain, the hindbrain, the midbrain
and the forebrain. These areas represent different evolutionary ages, meaning
the hindbrain evolved first, followed by the midbrain and finally the
forebrain. In fact, we can see some of the oldest animals on the planet. Fish
and reptiles only have a hind brain. Birds and mammals have a mid brain and
fore brain. But it's really the primates who have the most complex and
developed fore brains.